[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Bilmiyorum
bazen
Merhaba
[Müzik]
sonra
hayranlara
[Müzik]
Ey
Ancak
zıplamak
[Müzik]
veya
Hayır
[Müzik]
o
birçok yaz için
D
Bu doğru
agra'dan
[Müzik]
ya da değil
hepsinden
başaşağı
[Müzik]
Peki
ve bizimdi
[Müzik]
varlığımızın üretiminde
sadece 27'de
uymak
veya
[Müzik]
D
bir kere
Ey
[Müzik]
ve
Y
Evet
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
veya
[Müzik]
İyiyim
ve bu kadar
ya da çok daha iyi
[Müzik]
onlar hepsi
yine
[Müzik]
iyi ki
80'lerin sonlarında ve görerek biliyor
[Müzik]
aynısı çoğu deli
Bu method
[Müzik]
rahat
herkes
[Müzik]
Y
Evet
16 yıl ile
artı
bugün
onunla gidiyoruz
ve çok şeyim yoktu
ef
[Müzik]
bir tek
Ne
gerçek
ve şu
Merhaba
yine bir gece
[Alkış]
veya
şeyler ona sahip değildi
fazla
herkes
veya
artı
her oda
şort hakkında yorum yapmak
aşağıdan sipariş ver
[Müzik]
Aşk
s
Yeter
önceki
Ne istiyor
[Müzik]
ve bu yüzden
gerekli
D
şimdilik
Y
[Müzik]
çok ilginç
kesici ile
[Müzik]
şehir
veya
Niye
[Müzik]
ve
şimdiden yıllar
[Müzik]
Y
[Alkış]